Planet Fitness executives are likely thinking twice
while looking at its company value
tanking by $400 million.
Massive drop occurred after the gym canceled the membership of a woman
who complained about a biological man pretending to be a woman
inside the female locker room.
A 12 year old girl was sitting there in the locker room.
The incident happened earlier this month at a gym in Alaska.
Former Planet Fitness member Patricia Silva posted about it
I came in Monday,
there's a man in the woman's locker room shaving.
A little girl sitting on the corner.
She could have been 12 years old,
I don't know how old she was.
And a towel.
Kinda freaked out that there's a man shaving in her locker room.
When Silva complained that
Jim responded by canceling her membership
because she violated company policy
by taking a picture of the man in the locker room.
Before the incident,
Planet Fitness was worth a reported $5.3 billion.
After the media attention about a man in the woman's locker room
and it dropped to 4.9 billion.